[Applause]
i really want to know crypto
i've been watching your show for at
least a year yes yes yes yes here
thank you can you explain why the [ __ ]
it hasn't been regulated what it's being
used for why it's being promoted
why it looks like the government is just
going to let it go why it's at 50
000 you can buy a [ __ ] bitcoin for
what is happening with crypto
and i'm not going to fact check a single
thing there's no reason i don't even
know what's going on so
what alex jones doesn't know what's
going on
with crypto i just know a lot oh
i can tell you the secrets do you want
the secrets
i want to see can you handle the secrets
yeah can you handle i can handle
all right what
well obviously bitcoin is totally
controlled
that's the hammer that's the hammer
right there buy home you're gonna make a
lot of money doing it
buy home let's go talk to them um
i got approached by globalist
intelligence operations
probably i was like 10 years ago
bohemian grove
before that it was bilderberg it's
bilderberg how about you being real with
billboard
i wasn't that's not [ __ ] i don't
remember but he made grove rhymes
with uh with bilderberg i was at builder
that's where i'm at i know you got a lot
of white fans alex because you thought
those two
were rap bars
bilderberg bohemia
private right alright no no no
[Laughter]
no no seriously i'm at bilderberg i just
realized how often i say in all
seriousness
and it's frightening because he says
i'm morphing into jokes
all right i'm at bilderberg north of
london
wherever that town was like 10 years ago
right and max kaiser comes to me and he
says i have 10 000 bitcoins for you
this is the future it'll be the new
global currency
he's on record and i'm like drinking
wine and eating a [ __ ] steak at night
and i go
okay great i lost the laptop he put the
10 000 on it
today what's ten thousand bitcoin's
worth a lot ten thousand times fifty
five hundred
uh 510 million dollars yeah
510 million dollars you [ __ ] idiot
find that laptop
get
i swear to [ __ ] god this is real i
didn't know kaiser was like hooked up
with putin in the [ __ ]
easter bunny
so he goes i got oh my god
he didn't do this math until now he got
silently mad
so i'm sitting there with you know
friends
and i'm at this [ __ ] down i'm in the
basement of this hotel right next to
bilderberg
having like helicopters landing
globalists can you tell people what
bilderberg is real quick that's where
they make the teddy bears gotcha
i'm at a global government meeting i
just met with mi6
mi5 and the cia got you only because
they're going to arrest us if we don't
mess up
they probably were there yeah you
thought no this is all real [ __ ] max
kaiser
yeah come on bro come on bro i got a
feeling
assad was in the room alex you think so
[Music]
well anyway so i'm sitting there how do
you think he's massaging i don't know
i don't know what it works for anyways
the point is is that he puts
he said he got really mad because we're
sitting there eating steak and stuff he
goes all right i put ten thousand
bitcoin on his computer
he goes this is going to be the currency
this is like hundreds of millions of
dollars i usually get behind it
he was totally sure of it he's worked
with soros all of them and i go
he's like in cbs nbc pieces in the 80s
top broker
and i go okay great he jumps out of this
[ __ ] idiot
runs off won't talk to me like a year
because i would and later i'm like
where's that laptop where's that money i
don't even know
but no he was the guy told me it's gonna
it's gonna replace the dollar
and it's that japanese got it invented
it's satoshi
it's total globalist insider stuff and
i'm not saying don't be involved
obviously it's it's now been adopted uh
elon musk is involved
and i'm not smart like elon when they
came to him and said hey dude we won't
be our front guy
i'm like [ __ ] you don't even do it oh
you think they came to elon
they had to have right 100 now who is
that the u.s government has to be
involved with they
right i mean the u.s government has to
be involved with google and facebook
there's no way you give them that much
that's the only reason i'm still alive
is i'm like they have 50 colors and a
color tablet alex jones is just a little
color deal
it's like they're not going to kill me
because they they see it like as much as
i want to be smart
compared to the public that i don't even
know their master plans so i'm like a
a color they just used their painting
it's all they're doing this big
uh conductor deal and that's what
they're doing so is that your motivation
are you like i want to see what they're
painting
yeah that's it you just want to know
what the [ __ ] real thing is
exactly and people need to just pull
back and just go
what's going on so what's going on
some weird stuff apparently i think
aliens run it
really now are we connected with the
aliens we're made by the aliens
no we americans white people white blood
in america
i don't think i don't care what color
you are i really think
let me tell you no matter what color you
are your fate's bound to what happens
this planet
right so color really does not matter i
mean color matters because
color matters they play people off
against what color they are so like it's
real people make a deal about that but
when i spoke to joe right i asked joe
and i was like
i was like alex is coming on what should
i ask
you we're married he told me you guys
have been married for a while and he
says you haven't walked the same
since joe has a very large penis he's
packing right
over two feet long really oh are you
taking two feet dude
alpha
that's a joke